I love telling myself that size doesn’t
matter, but today that’s all we’re going
to talk about. Because we’re going
from the tiniest creatures in one
piece to behemoths that are so big, Mount
Everest wouldn’t even reach their knees.
But first, here is the smallest character
ever in One Piece. This is Mansherry,
the princess of the Tontatta. The
Tontatta tribe are tiny dwarves
the size of a chopstick that are actually so
small and fast, that the citizens of Dressrosa
rarely even see them. And Mansherry is
the smallest even among these dwarfs,
at only 20 centimeter or about 8 inches tall:
which is barely even the height of a dinner fork!
But moving from the smallest character to the
smallest Straw Hat, we have Tony Tony Chopper.
Now obviously Chopper can vary in size,
because his zoan type devil fruit allows
Chopper to change forms. And in his monster
form he is x tall, but for our purposes we’re
talking about Chopper in his base form: This
adorable baseball bat-sized doctor measures 90
centimeters or just under 3 feet. He’s just
a little guy and we love him most that way!
Compared to that, Monkey D. Luffy,
our main protagonist, is a true giant,
who comes in at 1.74 meters…when he’s not
stretched out that is. That’s about 5 foot 7,
so about the height of the average man worldwide,
which seems too specific to be a coincidence. But
thinking of Luffy staring down like…literally
any of the antagonists of the series,
we can tell things are about to get crazy
when it comes to how tall some characters
truly are. We’re not even talking about things
like the sea kings or the gates of justice yet.
First though, still possible in our real world
is Shanks. This Yonkou stands 2 meters tall or
about 6 foot 5. And while this IS pretty tall,
there ARE people who are this tall. For a frame
of reference, 2 meters is about the height of an
average door. Which means that from here on out,
every character we discuss is going to have to
lean down reaaally far whenever they walk into
a room. Or in some cases they just have no
hope of ever fitting through a door at all.
Which makes me wonder: Are buildings in the
One Piece world just…bigger than in real life?
Like, what about people like Jinbe, who’s a
whopping 3 meters tall. For the mathematically
impaired that’s one and a half Shankses -
or 10 feet tall! And this makes sense given
that in general, a lot of fishmen tend to be
bigger and stronger than the average human.
But on top of that Jinbe is also whale
shark fishman. In case you don’t know:
whale sharks just so happen to be the
biggest species of fish in the world…well,
our world anyway. so it’s no surprise that
he towers above many of his crew mates. - But
it’s of course NOTHING compared to some of the
absolutely massive sea creatures still coming up.
But for now we’re sticking to people as we go to
another one of the Yonkou - Luffy’s biggest rival,
Blackbeard. Marshall D. Teach is 3 meters and
44cm tall, which is over 11 feet! Hmmm…I never
imagined that Blackbeard was that much taller than
Jinbe. I mean, before now I always wondered how
he was ever able to give Shanks his signature
scars - and height isn’t everything, but he’s
almost TWICE as TALL as Shanks. But as you know,
he’s far from the biggest member of his crew…
He’s also nowhere near the size of the Shichibukai
Bartholomew Kuma. Whenever we see Kuma,
he straight out towers over regular people like
Luffy and co, from his first meeting with the
Straw Hats on Thriller Bark to him destroying the
entire crew on Sabaody Archipelago. This fearsome
former warlord is 6.89 meters tall - two times
the height of the already massive Blackbeard.
That’s 22 feet. This man is huge! We’ve heard
hints in the series in the most recent arc that
Kuma comes from a special race of people,
but it’s still hard to grasp how a person
who’s NOT a giant, can be as tall as two
elephants stacked on top of each other!
Kaidou in his base form, though, is even
taller at 7.10 meters. For some reference,
that’s about the height of a traffic
light. It’s no wonder that for the
fight with Luffy at Onigashima, he had
to take things to the rooftop. Sure,
he used the excuse of not being able to fit in
his crazy huge dragon form, but at 23 feet tall,,
it’s amazing he has any clearance in his hallways
whatsoever. Thankfully Onigashima is big enough
to fit the Numbers, so it’s probably the only
building in Wano that has enough space for him
to stretch his legs. It really makes you
wonder just how big Onigashima is, huh…
Big Mom stays true to her name, though, being
8.8 meters tall. That’s almost 29 feet! She’s
about the height of a 3 story building,
so it’s no wonder both her children and
her husbands are terrified of her! She really
takes the whole cake, being the biggest of all
the yonkou. It’s no wonder she’s sour about
Lola’s engagement to Loki, the Prince of the
Giants falling through. After all, if she had
a few more giants around, she might finally be
able to realize her dream of having everyone
sitting around a table at her own level.
Shirahoshi, the Mermaid Princess of
Fishman Island…is just absurdly big.
She’s 11.87 meters or 39 feet tall. It’s
wild that she’s so cowardly given that she
could look a Brachiosaurus in the eye, no
problem. It’s amazing that Vander Decken
was able to torment her so much, considering
that she could probably pick him up and yeet
him all the way to the surface if she
really wanted. Looking at her parents,
King Neptune and Queen Orohime…I mean, I don’t
even understand how she’s this big! Of course,
she’s nothing compared to the fearsome sea
kings she commands…but more on those later.
From here on out, every single entry is official
giant sized. Hajrudin, a member of the giant
pirates and now one of Luffy’s subordinates in
the Grand Fleet is 22 meters tall. That’s 72
feet or about the height of two telephone poles
stacked on top of each other. It really just
makes it much more impressive how easily Luffy
was able to take Hajrudin out at the Dressrosa
Coliseum. And even more impressive that Luffy has
a vertical leap that’s 13 times his own height.
The Thousand Sunny, the Straw Hat’s ship is
56 meters or 183 feet at its tallest point.
It makes sense that boats in the One Piece world
have to be huge given how massive the characters
we’ve already talked about are. Even being as
big as it is compared to their original ship,
the Going Merry, the Sunny is absolutely
dwarfed by other ships like Big Mom’s flagship.
Oars, the ancient giant, was 67 meters or
219 feet. This character was resurrected
as a zombie by Gekko Moriah’s shadow
ability. It’s no wonder Moriah wanted
this deceased warrior to be the center
piece of his undead army. Laying down,
Oars would measure the same length as a 747’s
wingspan. And if that’s hard to imagine,
let’s just say that jumbo jets…are
called “jumbo” jets for a good reason.
But even this ancient warrior can’t measure up
to Wadatsumi, the giant tiger blowfish fishman.
He’s 80 meters or 262 feet, which made him a
terrifying ally of the New Fishman pirates. It’s
wild that he’s based on a blowfish, too, because
that means he can puff himself up to become even
bigger. He’s by far the biggest fishman, but
he’s nothing compared to the biggest giant:
Sanjuan Wolf. One of Blackbeard’s Ten
Titanic Captains, Sanjuan Wolf is the
only giant who’s confirmed to have eaten
a devil fruit. And whatever devil fruit
it is…made him absolutely massive. Wolf is
183 meters tall. That’s 600 feet. And since
these numbers are just getting straight up
hard to imagine now, that’s the height of
the Space Needle. Sanjuan Wolf is so huge
that even though he’s a devil fruit user,
he can freely enter the ocean. He won’t drown
because he’s tall enough that his feet reach the
bottom and he can just stand in the sea without
having to worry about not being able to swim.
But now we go from the sea all the way up to the
sky, with one of One Piece’s longest creatures:
Nola, the snake who’s lived in Shandora
for 400 years! In all of that time,
Nola grew up from the cute little reptile
we see in Nolan and Calgara’s flashback
to this! Easily able to swallow Luffy whole.
This serpent is 200 meters or 656 feet long,
making him one of the oldest AND
biggest animals in all of One Piece.
However, Nola isn’t as big as Surume, a
300 meter tall Kraken who Luffy befriends
on the way to Fishman Island. That
translates to 984 feet or just shy
of the Eiffel Tower! As the crew descended
beneath the Red Line toward Fishman Island,
they didn’t expect to encounter a sea
creature so ridiculously big. Thankfully,
though, Luffy makes friends everywhere he goes,
and soon the crew had a new many-armed ally.
But from the entrance to the New World, now we
go back to the entrance of the Grand Line with
Laboon! The giant whale that swallowed the
crew as soon as they entered the Grand Line
through Reverse Mountain measures 400 meters
or 1312 feet from tail to head. Given how much
different he looks from when he was a baby, who
knows if Brook will even recognize this behemoth?
Apparently at the beginning of the Grand Line,
Oda was just really on a kick of introducing
absolutely huge monsters. Because now we go from
Laboon to the Island Eater Fish, the massive
island sized that almost swallowed Little Garden.
This 715 meter or 2345 feet beast is almost as
long as the Burj Khalifa is tall: you know, the
tallest building in the entire world. Luckily,
Dorry and Brogy had some giant sized strength
to be able to defeat it and save the day.
But now we move from giant creatures to the
biggest ship in the series: the Noah. Now
we’re at a scale so big that meters and feet
just aren’t going to cut it. At 2500 meters,
it’ll be easier to just say 2.5 kilometers. And
we also ahve our first entry over a mile at 8202
feet. A mile as we all know is 5280 feet…wait is
that how the Imperial measurement system works?
Why would it be 5280? Anyway - the Noah
is a massive ark built with the intention
of someday bringing the citizens of Fishman
Island up to the surface…unfortunately Luffy
destroyed it. Hopefully it gets rebuilt
before he also destroys Fishman Island!
But even the Noah doesn’t stack up to the biggest
door in all of anime. The Gates of Justice,
which we don’t have official measurements for,
but doing some real-life mathematics we can
estimate to be about 3 Kilometers or nearly 2
miles high, including the underwater portions.
The World Government has done some impressive
things to be able to control the entire world,
but among the most impressive? This
truly remarkable feat of engineering.
But now we go from a man-made structure
to one that is seemingly all natural:
The giant skull that Kaidou lives in on
Onigashima. This thing is 3.7 kilometers high
and over 2 miles high. It’s so massive it really
makes you wonder how big this ancient giant was
when it was alive. Which is why we calculated it!
You see…if you take the hypotenuse and multiply
by the square root of the quotient and the factor
in the permutations of the prime meridian…Okay,
actually it was a lot simpler than that.
If we assume an ancient giant has similar
proportions to a human, its total height
should be about 8 times the size of its
head. So we can assume that his full height
when alive was 29,320 meters or approximately
18 miles tall. Absurdly huge…but still not
the biggest thing we’ll get to on this list.
But first, some huge things that are
just a *bit* smaller than that. You see,
it just feels wrong to describe the Sea Kings
as small in any way, even when speaking in
relative terms. But at an average length
of 5 kilometers or about 3 miles…it’s no
wonder that Poseidon’s power to control these
leviathans is considered an ancient weapon.
Twice as big as that, though, is the Red
Line. at 10 kilometers or about 6 miles high,
the Red Line is taller than Mt. Everest. Which
is even more impressive when you consider that
the Red Line is like a Mt. Everest that stretches
around the entire circumference of the planet. I
can really see how having that in real life would
put a damper on any international travel plans. It
also makes it even more impressive that Fisher
Tiger scaled this thing with his bare hands.
But now we’re getting to the official
biggest things in the series: Zunesha,
including his legs that can easily reach the
sea floor so that he can walk around the ocean,
is 35 kilometers tall. That’s about 21.7
miles or in other words…the size of four
Mt. Everests. That really makes me feel
worse for Ryunosuke…rest in peace, friend…
This one is more of an estimation -
these shadows of the Shandian Warriors,
though just the shadows of
normal sized people measure
about 44 kilometers or 27 miles high. And
a lot of people confuse them with these:
The Florian Triangle Monsters. These mysterious
and unexplained creatures are based on Japanese
yokai called Umibozu, enormous sea monsters
said to drown sailors. AT our best estimate,
we can guess that these entities
are 54 kilometers or 33 miles high,
making them the BIGGEST thing in all of One
Piece. And in addition to this mystery there
are tons of other unexplained things in One
Piece, and you can check them all out in this
video where we go over every mystery that still
needs answered before the end of the series.